>> Tucker: AMAZING.
DR. SYRA MADAD THANKS FOR
COMING ON TONIGHT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE MAJOR
OUTBREAKS OF CARONAVIRUS IN
JAPAN, SOUTH KOREA AND
ITALY.
IN JAPAN ALL SCHOOLS ARE
CLOSED FOR THE NEXT MONTH AT
LEAST.
YET THE UNITED STATES IS
STILL RECEIVING FLIGHTS FROM
ALL THREE OF THOSE
COUNTRIES.
IN FACT, WE AREN’T EVEN
SCREENING ARRIVALS FOR THE
VIRUS.
CONGRESSWOMAN AND DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE TULSI
GABBARD OF HAWAII SAYS THAT
NEEDS TO CHANGE.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANKS SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO,.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: OBVIOUSLY THERE
IS AN ECONOMIC COST TO
SHUTTING DOWN ROOTS OR
PASSENGERS.
YOU THINK WE NEED TO DO IT
ANYWAY.
TELL US WHY.
>> WE DO.
BECAUSE, FIRST OF ALL, LET’S
LOOK AT THE FIRST MOVE THAT
WAS TAKEN BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO SUSPEND
FLIGHTS COMING FROM CHINA TO
PROTECT THE SAFETY AND
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF CARONAVIRUS
HERE TO OUR SHORES.
SIMILARLY, THIS IS WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH JAPAN,
SOUTH KOREA, AND ITALY.
THESE OTHER COUNTRIES WHO
ARE GOING THROUGH A SERIOUS
OUTBREAK THAT THEY ARE
DEALING WITH, AND LIKE YOU
SAID, THERE IS STILL NO
SCREENING TAKING PLACE, NOT
ONLY ON ARRIVAL WITH PEOPLE
COMING HERE, BUT WHAT I
THINK NEEDS TO BE DONE IS
PEOPLE SHOULD BE TESTED
BEFORE THEY GET ON THE
PLANE.
IN THAT CASE AND IN THAT
INSTANCE, PEOPLE ARE TESTED,
THEY COME OUT NEGATIVE, THEN
THEY CAN GO ABOUT THEIR
BUSINESS.
THIS WILL HAVE SOME ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
THERE’S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
BUT, THAT IMPACT IN THE
SHORT-TERM NOW BY TAKING
THIS ACTION WILL PALE IN
COMPARISON TO THE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP AND CHALLENGES WE
WILL FACE IN THIS COUNTRY IF
THESE FLIGHTS ARE ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE, PEOPLE ARE COMING
HERE, POTENTIALLY INFECTED
WITH THIS VIRUS.
AND THEN IT IS ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE TO SPREAD.
THE HARDSHIP ON THE LEVEES
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
THE HARDSHIP ON OUR ECONOMY
WILL BE FAR-REACHING AND
LONGER LASTING.
>> JUST TO PUT THIS IN
CONTEST FOR OUR VIEWERS.
YOU REPRESENT, OF COURSE,
THE STAY OF IOWA, WHICH I
WOULD BELT HAS NOR DIRECT
FLIGHTS TO ASIA THAN ANY
OTHER PLACE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IT’S A MAJOR SOURCE OF
REVENUE FOR YOUR STATE.
AND SO THIS WOULD MEAN
HAWAII TAKE AS BIG HIT.
BUT YOU ARE STILL IN FAVOR
OF IT.
THAT’S HOW CONCERNED YOU
ARE.
>> WE HAVE TO HAVE FORESIGHT
AND RECOGNIZE THE PRIORITY
FOR OUR LEADERS IS TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY AND HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING OF THE PEOPLE OF
MY HOME STATE OF HAWAII, THE
PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY AND
TAKING THIS STEP NOW IS
NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
BECAUSE IF WE DON’T, THEN
IT’S TOO LATE.
THEN THE CARONAVIRUS MAY
HAVE ALREADY TAKEN ROOT AND
AGAIN YOU ARE LOOKING AT
IMPACT ON JOBS.
IMPACT ON SCHOOLS.
IMPACT, YES, ON A STATE LIKE
OURS THAT’S HEAVILY FUNDED
ON TOURISM THAT WILL BE FAR
MORE LONG LASTING AND
DEVASTATING.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A
CONVERSATION THAT’S KIND OF
POPPED UP A COUPLE OF TIMES
IN THE LAST WEEK.
EACH TIME IT DOES THE PEOPLE
WHO RAISE IT ARE DENOUNCED
AS XENOPHOBIA I HOW WOULD YOU.
>> IT’S LOOKING AT FACTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE HAS BEEN
XENOPHOBIA AROUND THIS
OUTBREAK THAT BEGAN IN CHINA
THAT MUST BE DENOUNCED.
REALLY WHAT WE’RE TALKING
ABOUT IS THE UNITED STATES,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS WELL
AS HOW SMALL THIS GLOBAL
COMMUNITY IS AND HOW
ESSENTIAL IT IS THAT WE WORK
WITH OTHER COUNTRIES TO BE
ABLE TO PREVENT THIS FROM
BECOMING AN ALL-OUT
PANDEMIC.
AND SO, LOOK, I WANT TO MAKE
A DIRECT APPEAL TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP AT THIS POINT.
TO BREAK THROUGH THE
BUREAUCRACY, BREAK THROUGH
THE RED TAPE THAT WE’RE
SEEING FROM AGENCIES LIKE
THE CDC AND THE FDA IN ORDER
TO BROADEN THE TESTING
CRITERIA, TO MAKE IT SO THAT
ANYONE WHO HAS SYMPTOMS CAN
ACTUALLY GET A TEST.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
TESTS ARE READILY AVAILABLE,
WHETHER IT’S IN A DOCTOR’S
OFFICE.
IN A WANT WHO, AT OUR
AIRPORTS.
OR EVEN AS THEY ARE DOING IN
COUNTRIES LIKE SCOTLAND AND
SOUTH KOREA.
THERE’S A DRY THREW STATION.
YOU CAN GO IN AND GET THE
TEST AND BE IN AND OUTENNED
N. LESS THAN 10 MINUTES
RATHER THAN HAVING THE KIND
OF PROLONGED TESTING THAT WE
ARE HAVING NOW.
WHERE THE CDC ONLY TEST AS
VERY FEW PEOPLE BECAUSE OF
THEIR NARROW CRITERIA.
AND THEN HAVE YOU GOT TO
WAIT FOUR DAYS IF YOU ARE
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO GET
TESTED POTENTIALLY IF YOU
HAVE THE VIRUS PUTTING YOU
IN A PLACE WHERE YOU ARE
EXPOSING OTHER PEOPLE AND
PUTTING THEM AT RISK.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET ON THE
BALL ON THIS.
>> Tucker: IT SEEMS LIKE A
NO-BRAINER, FOR SURE.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANK YOU SO